[موسيقى]
احدى ليالي الشتاء الطويل
ابردها السادس من فبراير درجه الحراره صفر
بالضبط
تحت سقف البيت الدافئ احلام بغد يشبه
الامس
لم يكن افضل
انها الرابعه
وسبعه عشره دقيقه
هل هذا حلم ايضا
ليس دوارا
انها هزه مستمره
لا تتوقف
حتما ستتيقظ الجميع
دقيقه واربع ثوان كسرت كل شيء الزمن
الاحلام والمستقبل
اخذت الامينينا من النوم الى الموت في
مخاض الانقاض قبل انتشال ثلاثه واربعين
الفا وخمسمائه منهم جثثا
هي دقيقه زلزال ضخم بقوه
7.8 درجات على مقياس ريختر وهنا في غاز
عنتاب في نورداك حجم الكارثه لا يصدق
اختفت ملامح الحي وكان الزلزاله وقع على
سطح الارض صحيح نسبيا عمقه كان 18 كيلو
متر وهذه البقعه حيث اقف ليست المركز او
البؤره
الكارثه وقعت في بازرجيك شمالي المحافظه
في كهرمان مرعش المنكوبه وسنعلم لاحقا ان
نكبتها ستحل على عشر مقاطعات جنوبيه اخرى
امتد اثر الزلزال اليها ليدمر اكثر من 105
الاف مبنى على 500 كم
زلزال ثان لا ليس بعد هذه هزه ارتداديه
بقوه
6.4 درجات ستاتي على المزيد من المباني
والارواح
وسيليها اكثر
سبعه الاف ومئتي هزه
لكن الزلزال الاول كان بقوه
خمسمائه قنبله نوويه
كانها لم تكن يوما مدينه تبدل ضجيج الحياه
بصرخات الموت يسمعها الناجون كما
المحاصرون بالردم في كل مكان
والبستان المدمره على موعد مع الضربه
الثانيه تمحي حكاياتي واثر كبار وصغار لا
يزالون تحت اثر وهول الصدمه الاولى
[موسيقى]
انها الواحده واربع وثلاثون دقيقه ظهرا
الان على صوت جرافات تزيح انقاد وركام
بيوت ابتلعت سكانها واخرى تهدم ما تبقى من
خرسانه عرضتها ثنائيه الزلزلين والفساد
مصيرها الانهيار عاجلا ام اجلا 50 الف
مبنى واكثر من هذا المكان والزمان بات
الوقت يقاس بخساره الارواح سباق مع الموت
لكبح العداد المفجع للوفيات المؤكده واخر
مع الصقيع وتدني الحراره ليلا الى خمسه
عشره درجه تحت الصفر تحديدا في البستان
وللمفقودين عداد اخر لا يوثقه سوى الناجين
وشهاداتهم بمن ترك خلفهم دون حظ او رائحه
هكذا سجلت لحظات الموت وقليل من البطوله
عليه فرق انقاذ محليه ودوليه من 90 دوله
استنفذت كل ادواتها ولكل
معداته التقنيه والتقليديه المجربه
والخاضعه للاختبار الفئران المدربه على
كشف الالغام في افريقيا حضرت من بلجيكا
على الرقعه التركيه المنكوبه بحقيبه ظهر
وكاميرات لترصد من شقوق الركام وفسحاته
الضيقه صوتا او حركه مرجوه
345 الف شقه سكنيه استنسخ قدر ساكنيها
ولربما كان مصيرهم الحياه لو كانت هذه
الصوره الطبقيه الافتراضيه توفرت واقعيا
لنجدتهم غير ان الصور من باطن الارض الى
علو السماء لا تنقذوا ارواحا سبقها سيف
الوقت واخطاء الاغاثه والاستجابه المتاخره
فمن ظن في ظلمه الركان لانه وحيد
اخطا الصوره تزداد قتامه من ارتفاع تحليق
المسيرات او هكذا يراد منها برصدها حجم
الضرر الذي حل باكثر من 26 مليون شخص 15
مليونا في تركيا و11 مليون متضرر تفصلهم
الحدود الجنوبيه على الجانب الاخر البؤس
لن يكون مؤقتا والواقع لا يغيره تاريخ ولا
مفاجات او كوارث طبيعيه ان كانت نورداك
اصلاحيه بزرجيك البستان وانطاكيا في تركيا
الاكثر تاثرا فعنوان مقاس الكارثه بوقعها
الاعنف تج لى في جنديرس عفرين سلقين حارم
وجبله السوريه
النجوم منهم مصيرهم العراء الدائم غالبا
او المغلف بخيام تاخرت لن ينسى منهم من
تبقت لديه رفاهيه الذكرى ان اولى قوافل
النجده الشحيحه المنقوصه دخلت مناطقهم بعد
اليوم الخامس من وقوع الكارثه يعيش خمسه
ملايين ونصف المليون السوري مع خذلانا قتل
كذلك عددا يبقى غير معلوم
ما نعلمه ان نحو سبعه الاف شخص قضى تحت
انقاض مباني انتهتكت بفعل
القصف نواه
وتوقف البحث عن المزيد لنقص المعدات
والارض هنا بما يفوق الحصيله غير المؤكده
للضحايا
احتضنت المزيد
اعادتهم كارثه الزلزال من رحله لجوهم الى
تركيا
جثثا هامده
بين السياسي والانساني كثير من المفارقات
وانتشابه مسرحات دمار وتوحدت صيحات الالم
ان كانت تحديات تركيا مدهونه بالوقت في
الاسعاف والانقاذ وانتشار الجثث ومن ثم
اعاده الاعمار بتكلفه تقدر بمئه مليار
دولار
فاقارب الساعه
لملايين السوريين احياء وامواتا في عهده
الزلزال توقفت عند الرابعه
عشره دقيقه فجر السادس من فبراير 2023